these drugs coming from Mexico is going
to get far more difficult the party's
newly elected government is moving
rapidly toward legalizing marijuana
meanwhile its highest court has struck
down the country's law authorizing the
military's deployment against the drug
cartels Mexico then could soon be far
more tolerant of drugs and the cartels
meanwhile heroin brought in
overwhelmingly from Mexico is killing
tens of thousands of Americans every
year Tucker just spoke with an Arizona
sheriff about the threat of Mexican
heroin his Tucker opioids are killing
tens of thousands of Americans every
year it's an epidemic it's being driven
in part by prescription drugs but not
only by prescription drugs also heroin
more of it is being smuggled into this
country than ever before and almost all
of that heroin is coming from Mexico
across our poorest southern border Matt
Thomas is the deputy chief of police in
Pinal County Arizona and he joins us
tonight
chief Thomas thanks very much for coming
on give us a sense and this is something
that's rarely discussed in Washington
but of the scale of opioid smuggling
across our southern border into the
United States well we've seen a
significant increase since 2014 it used
to be that Arizona our southern borders
marijuana was the cash crop for the
Sinaloa cartel specifically that kind of
is the main cartel for our state and
there was a significant shift starting
in 2014 where the marijuana smuggling
started to decline and we started to see
a significant increase in the smuggling
of heroin fentanyl and methamphetamine
fentanyl - yes okay so I mean give us a
sense like large amounts enough that
they would help drive the epidemic
that's killing so many Americans oh
absolutely especially the fentanyl
because such small doses are so lethal
and so it'd be that particular drug
becomes a danger both for anybody that
is using it but our officers as well as
well we've had several exposures in our
state where officers have been
exposed to phenyl and then they've had
to get the the narcan to help reverse
the effects so that they don't die from
the exposure we've had citizens same
thing they overdose on it because it's
much stronger than heroin so we have the
heroin problem but now we're having the
fentanyl problem and that is becoming a
bigger crisis for us because it's so
dangerous and we're seeing it it's
coming in the format of essentially fake
pills so what the cartels are sending up
are what are being sold as oxy but it's
fake and it has the fentanyl in it and
it's much stronger more potent and more
dangerous so we just had on the screen
on if you could see it video of drug
tunnels crossing the border into the
United States how common are those in
your county in our County not common
because we are we're off the border
about 70 miles and the county is unique
being that we're off the border 70 miles
but it's open desert to the border
that's what kind of makes us more like a
border county but I for the border
counties in the state Pima County
Cochise County Yuma County yes very
common because the sinaloans essentially
are the masterminds behind those tunnels
in Arizona being predominantly Sinaloa
cartel ran very common to see tunnels
throughout our state do you think
Washington which is trying to respond to
the opioid crisis that's killing so many
people do you think that in Washington
lawmakers have a sense of where these
drugs are coming from I think they have
a sense of where they're coming from I
mean they would have to have their heads
buried pretty deep in the sand to not
have a sense of that after all these
years I
we kind of know where the source is but
I don't think they have a sense of the
magnitude of what's coming across the
border how easy it is to get across the
border and how adversely it's affecting
all of our communities and you know from
the smallest rural community
all the way up to your metropolitan
areas it's having a very negative effect
and you know it's it's kind of our fault
on the american side where the consumers
we've kind of created this problem and
and they're just it's a demand driven
thing yeah it would be nice to stop it
thank you very much for telling us that
appreciate it absolutely